el presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
ha visitado hoy la ciudad de San
Sebastián la más afectada por las
lluvias que han golpeado el litoral
norte de San Pablo él ha hecho un
discurso político ha prometido a ayudar
como Gobierno Federal a la
reconstrucción de las áreas destrozadas
por los deslizamientos junto al gobierno
del estado de San Pablo que es liderado
por tarsicio de freídas un ex Aliado del
presidente Jair bolsonaro ha recordado
que junto también al ayuntamiento de San
Pablo es importante superar las
diferencias ideológicas para ayudar a la
población muy castigada hemos visto en
esos días a muchas personas que lo han
perdido todo una cena recurrente
Lamentablemente en muchas regiones de
Brasil en esos momentos hay seis
ciudades en estado de calamidad algunas
de ellas son destinos turísticos
conocidos Porque muchos paulistas los
habitantes de San Pablo pasen ahí sus
vacaciones estamos en el verano Tropical
suele llover mucho pero esas lluvias son
fuera de lo común y el gobernador de San
Pablo ha recordado que la carretera que
une San Pablo corrió de Janeiro está
parcialmente destrozada hay 10 puntos de
bloqueos y es incluso posible que
algunos puntos hayan desaparecido para
siempre